[Musique]
au début elle me tenait des choses
équilibre parfait le sommeil tarte
elle faire très ou sheila faut il pue
[Musique]
lorsque l'on danse la danse d'un autre
on se fait à l'image de son créateur
[Musique]
je n'en reviens pas d'être ici madame
blanc est incroyable
sa manière de nous transmettre son
expérience vous devez décider ce que
vous voulez être pour cette compagnie
cette compagnie cache bien plus de ce
grec et noir
[Musique]
vous vivez avec des gens très dangereux
sa mère trois dieux trop a tellement
rtn prat maire lacrymal
r suspiria aux ténèbres
un soupir
[Musique]
tu a conclu une espèce d'accord avec
elle
[Musique]
je ne vois pas du tout de quoi tu parles
[Applaudissements]
quel désordre
celui de l'extérieur
[Musique]
celui de la retirer
celui qui vient
chiche
[Musique]